ready
yes you can come tomorrow for the under 50
sinks well i just wanted to ask by
chance i heard some doctor on this
topic but we have to talk together the
day after the ordination of the bishop
asked me to take on this
position which i certainly never had
first thought exorcist
[Music]
we study in theology something
about the devil and evil then
we see that people have a
very distant idea both of the devil many
times of evil is much more often than the
exorcist I understood that the speech
could be more  interesting and it
was necessary to cast out the first demon which
was a thing of ignorance the
crass ignorance both on these topics and the
bad information that is given
many people I found worried about
small details for illnesses for
disorders of the psychic sphere very
convinced that it was the
devil not  they become aware of the
demonic actions that only in our
history in our society
and good p  to discard that a person is
affected by psychic disorders practicing
the exorcism prayers would be
purely illusory and harmful
the great confusion in our world
confusing the psychiatric with demonic
building verse being faced with the
demoniac real experience
very much 1 are perfectly
sane the  superfine intelligence and
used for the sea and they know that I
wanted to meet that's when it happens
somehow it also becomes a clash
with a lot of wickedness with a trail of
evil that chases you for a long time
ends care was to have met
people in the church I am amazed
that jesus first changed ideas finds it
in the synagogue
the exorcistic action relocating the
world in the ratio there is the reason for being
in things it means that it is placed
within nature and it is not a
law revealed by some religion but it is
intrinsic  the problem with nature
is that many think that
being possessed by the devil means
of the dem  onio is a bolt from the blue
that enters their life but in the gospel
we find something different when jesus
meets the man possessed by the devil and
right written and aca pneumatic tailor
say inside a spirit in pure then
indicates that the man is gone yes
it is built and stabilized inside an
evil spirit and not the opposite
Saint Augustine said the devil
would have no power over you if there
was not your consent
being this way it is well understood that
the real possessed act from the
church obviously flee  from
the exorcist our action and above all to
prevent people from ending up badly and to
free them when they have fallen
we say that I still have the liberation
through the help the intervention
prayer in the church can take place if
the person leaves and that I  says rajo as
long as we are alive we can make
choices to exercise our free
will
as the saying goes fantasy life there is
hope
[Music]
[  Music]